Transcriber: Bassant El-Ghazaly
المدقّق: rana heloun
وحملات توعية،
وتظهر في الأخبار بعنوان “لا للتنمر“.
نحن في العادة شعب يحب أن يضحك كثيرًا.
وبلا شك كلنا نقوم بنفس الأمر.
لكن كلمة التنمر تمثل في مضمونها
قصة حزينة لصاحب المشكلة.
بمعنى أصح كلما زاد التنمر، كلما زاد
الأذى النفسي الواقع على صاحب المشكلة.
أنا هنا اليوم لأحكي لكم
لأي مدى قد تكون الكلمة
سبب في أذى نفسي لدرجة أن تؤدي إلى
تدمير طموح إنسان وتحطيم أحلامه.
بدأت قصتي بمرض مزمن
الذي يُسمى أيضَا بمرض العصر.
أصبت بمرض السكر وأنا أبلغ 9 سنوات،
طفلة لا حول لها ولا قوة.
كل ما أفكر فيه أن آكل كل ما أريد
وأن ألعب وأجري بلا قيود.
دون تحفظات على حركتي ولا حياتي عامةً.
كانت أول مرة أرى الحزن في عيون والديّ
وأرى والدي متأثرًا ووالدتي تبكي،
ولا أفهم سبب حزنهما.
ظننت أنني سأشفى بعد حين.
كان الموضوع بالنسبة لي شبيه بالكارثة.
كيف أُحرم من تناول الطعام المفضل عندي.
بدأ الموضوع يكبر بالتدريج
واكتشفت إني بحاجة لحقن أنسولين يوميًا.
ولابد أيضًا من حقن يوميًا
لمتابعة مستوى السكر في الدم.
ظننت في البداية أن الموضوع
فترة مؤقتة مثل علاج البرد.
أي فترة سآخذ بها الحقن وستمر
وكنت أخبرهم أني انتهيت من الحقن
فدعوني أعود لحياتي العادية
ولتعود الحياة لمجراها الطبيعي.
مرت فترة وهم يشرحون لي إنه مرض مزمن
ليس مؤقت وسيبقى معي كل حياتي.
مرت الأعوام واكتشفت أمرًا غريبًا جداً.
بعض الأشخاص يخفون أمر مرضهم.
تعاملت مع أطفال في سني يخفون مرضهم.
كأن المرض عيب أو مشكلة
لا يصح أن تظهر للناس،
ولو قلت أنني مُصابة بالسكر سيستنكره الناس.
أكثر المواقف العالقة في ذهني حتى اليوم
هي نظرات الشفقة وكلام بعض الناس،
مثل “مسكينة، مريضة سكر” كيف ستكمل حياتها،
ما زالت صغيرة جدًا،
كيف سيكون مستقبلها،
كنت أتألم لسماع تلك العبارات،
وألمي منها كان أكثر من ألم حقنة الأنسولين.
بعد فترة بدأت اسمع المزيد:
“مسكينة أنت مريضة بالسكر“.
نظرات الشفقة لفتاة مريضة سكر
كانت تشعرني بالنقص ولكنه غير حقيقي.
كانوا أهلي على النقيض من تلك التصرفات.
لأكون منصفة لم أسمع منهم كلمة آلمتني
أو أشعرتني بأني إنسانة غير طبيعية أبدًا.
كنت دائما أراهم بجانبي،
على الرغم من خوفهم عليّ حتى اليوم،
إلا إن سمة علاقتنا كانت الدعم المستمر.
مرت فترة والشيء بالشيء يذكر كما يقال،
مثل ما كان للسكر جانب مظلم وعنيف
والكثير من المعاناة،
وكم هي موجعة حقن الإنسولين بالنسبة لي،
إلا أنه يوجد للسكر جانب مضيء في حياتي.
علمني أهمية كلمة النظام
وتناول الطعام بنظام والاهتمام بالصحة.
عدت فترة والأمور غير مستقرة،
ولا زلت لا أفهم سبب مرضي.
حتى قررت عدم الاستسلام لكلام الناس،
لأنه لا يساعد على التقدم ولكن يعرقل.
فكرت في طموحي
والهدف الذي أريد الوصول له،
وكيف أبدأ في تحقيق ذلك.
كان لدي حلم صغير أن ألتحق
بمدرسة المتفوقين للعلوم والتكنولوجيا،
وفعلًا تقدمت لاختبارات المدرسة
ونجحت في اختبارات القبول،
وتم قبولي في المدرسة.
يوم قبولي في المدرسة كان استثنائي،
كنت أسعد إنسانة في هذه الدنيا.
حينها انقسم الناس حولي إلى فريقين،
فريق سعيد جدًا،
ولقبوني ب “زويل”
تشبيهًا بالعالم (أحمد زويل)،
والفريق الثاني لامني
وألقوا العيب على والديّ؛
قائلين: “كيف تسمحون لابنتكم
بالانتساب لمدرسة داخلية؟“.
“كيف ستشعرون بالأمان على ابنتكم
وهي بعيدة ومريضة؟“.
اتهم البعض أهلي بالقسوة
لأنهم سمحوا لي بالاستقلال
والمكوث في مدرسة داخلية لوحدي.
وعلى الرغم من كل الانتقادات
التي سمعتها آنذاك
إلا إني لم أهتم أبدًا.
كان هدفي إكمال طريقي ودخول المدرسة.
كل كلمة يقولونها تشعرني إني غير طبيعية
وليس لي الحق في أن احقق جزء من طموحي.
ثم دخلت المدرسة.
وبعد دخولي المدرسة
اكتشفت إن الموضوع ليس بالسهولة المتوقعة؛
أن ابتعد عن أبي وأمي فجأة وأنا طفلة.
لم يكن الموضوع بالسهولة التي تخيلتها
أني سأقف على الأرض بثبات.
مر عامان في المدرسة وتعلمت الكثير.
بنيت شخصية مختلفة تمامًا
عن التي اعتدت أن أكون.
تعلمت كيف أفكر تفكير منطقي سليم
وكيف أتعامل مع الأمور باستراتيجية.
أهم ما تعلمته كان الاعتماد على نفسي.
من وقت دخولي المدرسة فهمت أكثر
عاقبات مرضي وسببه
وقرأت عنه أكثر.
وضعت المدرسة حجر الأساس لي.